it's well known that a U.S president can
only serve two terms but as most of you
watching will know there is one very
notable exception to this Franklin
Delano Roosevelt he served four terms
between 1933 and 1945 which was when he
took the important constitutional
decision to die but given that every
president before and after him had only
served a maximum of two terms how did
the American people react to him doing
this and did anybody try to stop him now
the two-term limit Presidents abided by
originated with George Washington who
towards the end of his second term
realized that he hated his job and so
opted not to run again he did this not
because he believed that there should be
a two-term limit but the leaders should
be willing to hand over power without
fuss and later when it became clear that
John Adams wasn't going to win a second
term some of Washington's supporters
asked for him to run for a third he said
no because he was too busy being happily
retired and many saw this as Washington
condemning third terms but this was just
convention not law so did any other
presidents try to run for a third term
well yes quite a few of them the first
president to openly flirt with breaking
the convention
Ulysses S Grant however his party
refused to nominate him after this
Grover Cleveland was offered a third run
in 1896 by his party but he was well
aware that everybody hated him at this
point and so he declined so the first
president with any genuine hope of being
re-elected to a third term was none
other than Theodore Roosevelt he was
offered a third term by his party but he
refused wanting to respect Washington's
precedent however when he realized his
successor sucked he tried to win the
Republican nomination again but they
stayed with William Taft as such new
party the Bull Moose Party he ran
against Taft split the vote and managed
a respectable second place to Woodrow
Wilson Wilson had hoped for a third term
but his party refused to nominate him
meaning that up until FDR the convention
stayed intact so what exactly changed
with Roosevelt well with World War II
raging in Europe FDR believed that his
opponent and professional stupid name
have a Wendell Wilkie would leave
Britain to its fate and also undo his
new deal policies what made this time
different was that his party agreed now
as you can guess a third run was quite
contentious the Republican Party accused
Roosevelt of being a dictator and
waiting in the third term was
Un-American broadly though most
Americans were much more concerned with
navigating through the tumultuous times
and ultimately Roosevelt was seen as
more trustworthy in economic and foreign
policy matters than Wilkie which is why
he won the 1940 election handily he ran
for and won a fourth term which shocked
precisely zero people but he died
shortly afterwards and by 1947 there
were many politicians in both parties
who were concerned that long-running
presidents could lead to National
stagnancy this political concern is what
the 22nd amendment was put forward this
banned presidents from serving for more
than two terms the 22nd amendment had
one exception Harry Truman this was
because he was already president and so
he was allowed to run again if he wanted
he tried but his unpopularity soon made
it clear that his party would have
preferred to elect literally anybody
else and so he stood down there by
ending the last attempt at there ever
being a three-term president I hope you
enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James bizonette
Kelly moneymaker corshow wolf Sky
Chappelle kartowitzker Jerry lambdin
Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter Jordan Longley
rod D Martin why in hockey Marcus arsner
Captain side dog Marvin Castle Spencer
Lightfoot Winston caywood boogly Wiggly
Daniel tabian kamoon Yoon Miss izet
Gustav Swan Aaron the white Anthony
Beckett the mcwhopper Maggie pascowski
Coppertone spinning three plates she
went in words about books podcast and
Charles the first